Oh sir first of all can you join me in a
round of applause for my beautiful and
very talented colleagues in documentary
I want to work with them one day so I
have to butter love please hey Lucas
Judy Heumann
ed Roberts a lot of you may or may not
know those names but without those
individuals everything you see today
from curb cuts to ramps to to the way we
construct buildings to how you teach
kids with special needs all of that then
I'm gonna go out and live here and say
this all of that start it with this
particular group of men and women in
Berkeley in the 1970s and you know they
wake up they were fused to be limited
and defined by by the by by their
perceived physical limitations every
single morning hale and and millions of
people like him around the world wake up
and all they want to do is just live
their lives independently all they want
to do is is be able to live their lives
with with courage and dignity and
respect every single day and this film I
hope is a testament to a man who I
believe is an American Hero hails helmet
and his stick and his letter board I
believe especially been listening right
now it belongs in the Smithsonian it
really does and it belongs for future
generations to be able to understand
that the great sacrifice is that he lay
down he and many others like him laid
down every single day for all of us
because all of us are connected to to
disability disability affects all of us
all of us on that thin line as he says
in the movie and any of us kidney you
know we'll be able to could can feel
these effects in our daily lives I want
to thank my co-producer mr. Isaac Smith
I can't see him right now but can he
please stand
he came up on say they told us not to
bring people on stage but we did it
anyway so I apologize um I told him that
come but that's okay he's a great guy
he's a good guy um you know also his
beautiful wife Noble I want to thank you
for for your sacrificing your support
through this process I know it was not
easy to posh it minkovski who's our
who's my uh who worked specifically with
the archive in this film which i think
was so crucial to go back deep into
those archives to to understand what was
going on in Berkeley in the 1970s to to
Joanie Bon Temps whose music I think
really made this film just click for
people he's amazing and I want to thank
him he's standing up john egg stand up
right now and um last but not least I
want to thank the Academy I think this
organization and I'm gonna be honest I
learned a lot this week this week being
with you guys you know you're
surprisingly down-to-earth in a way I
didn't expect oh and you're but you're
cool and you but but the thing is though
you do great work you were you were
truly an American institution and and
and you you you know it's one of those
things where you take stories that are
underrepresented and you shine this
spotlight into them and I think that's
the great thing about film you see you
shine the spotlight into dark areas that
that a lot of people fear to go and I
want to thank you for this program and I
will thank you for all that you do
because you do keep us moving and last
but not least I want to thank Hale his
story has been Ford forty years in the
making it's a long time coming and the
last thing I'm gonna say is hail - hail
thank you very much